- "Cobra Kai" is a spin-off
of the popular '80s movie,
of course, starring Ralph Macchio.
But karate, as an art form,
has been around forever.
And I wanted to learn a
bit more about karate,
so I looked it up on Wikipedia.
- Oh really?
- Oh, for fuck's sake,
not this again.
- Wait, what, why are
you so tired of this?
I wanted to really do my due diligence,
so I memorized the entry.
I mean if you're so into the show,
- She memorized Jean-Claude
Van Damme's Wikipedia page
and then just rattled it off.
- I'm just trying to
educate you a little bit
more about karate.
If you're so into the
show, you should know
that karate began as a
common fighting system
known as Te and after trade
relationships were established
with the Ming Dynasty of
China in 1372, by King Satto,
some forms of Chinese
martial arts were introduced
to the Ryukyu Islands by
the visitors from China,
particularly Fujian Chinese families
who moved to Okinawa around 1392
(voice fades out)
(dream sequence music)
- Oh, okay.
- Oh no.
- What the (laughing).
What is going on right now?
Is that, it's Miguel.
It's Demetri.
- What up?
- Wait, did we all have a Power Cup.
Xolo, Gianni, Jacob-
- What's going on?
- I can't believe this
is happening right now.
You guys are just playing Street Fighter?
- Yeah.
- We're just running
up some Street Fighter.
You wanna join us?
- We figured it-
The triumphant return.
You wanna play some
Street Fighter with us?
- Has there been practicing going on?
Am I gonna get my butt kicked?
- If by practicing you
mean button mashing,
then yes, we have been
doing a lot of that.
- Like last minute button mashing.
We just found out what things happen.
Yeah, we're gonna lose.
- I still don't even know
how to do some of the moves.
- Wait, so-
- I don't know.
- You guys don't play Street Fighter?
- No.
- No, we fight on the streets.
- Oh, you just fight for real.
- We live Street Fighter.
- How are you guys doing?
You guys have wrapped season four, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Just recently.
- Yeah, just recently.
- Do you want spoilers?
- I do, but chat probably,
we just saw Terry Silver
teased, which is huge.
It's ridiculous.
Question, did you guys see
the "Karate Kid" movies
before booking or did you do it after?
- Xolo was a huge fan.
- Watched all of 'em.
- I was a huge fan of the "Karate Kid".
I had posters all over my room,
so this is kind of-
- Seriously?
- a dream come true.
Unfortunately, no,
they're just teasing me.
I hadn't seen the movies
before I booked the project,
so I didn't get a chance to see 'em.
But now I've now I've had,
right, that is the biggest offense
but now I've seen all of them.
- That's awesome.
It's only offense if you've
never saw 'em, that's it.
- Right, exactly, Gianni.
- That's it, you're a winner.
You're all winners.
- Whoa, I saw "Karate Kid"
one and two.
I haven't seen three.
(Xolo laughing)
- You haven't seen three?
- So Terry Silver means nothing to you?
- But that's the one with Terry Silver.
- I'm so mad right now.
- I haven't seen it before
I got the "Cobra Kai".
- Right, gotcha.
- Oh, good save, good save.
- I know about the
billionaire Terry Silver
with the ponytail.
Dude, he's tall.
- Is he?
- Yeah, Tom is tall.
- I thought I was tall.
- He's 6'2" easy.
- Yeah.
(guys laughing)
- Are we getting straight into a fight?
Are we doing a fight?
We are.
- Yeah, we can do it.
You wanna go at it.
- I don't know what I was doing.
Okay, let's do it.
- Who do you wanna fight first?
- I think you guys should nominate.
You guys should nominate.
- I think Gianni should go first.
- Oh, okay, so we're
saving the best for first.
- I wanna say, I think Gianni's the best
out of us or maybe just
picks the best character.
- I was about to say that.
- And Gianni, you gotta teach
him a lesson with that guy.
- Don't hype me up this much, man.
You're gonna regret it.
Okay, oh, what the hell?
- Oh, we're going Ken.
- Okay.
I'll be, oh no, not Ken.
I got my guy, this guy right here.
- You've got the Dhalsim?
- Yeah, he's my favorite.
He reminds me of myself just
because he has really long drawn limbs.
- 'Cause he has stretchy limbs.
- Yeah, 'cause he's bald.
- Are you referring to yoga?
- No, I'm not the most
flexible guy in the world,
so definitely don't wanna see me do yoga.
That would be bad.
But you know, I can dream.
- You can do the splits
though, involuntarily.
- You kick ass in the show, dude.
- That's true.
Thank you, thank you, yeah.
I got that good Crescent kick on Hawk
at the very end of season two.
- All right, here we go.
- All right, let's see.
Whoa, oh, I've always wanted
to do the Vegas one, okay.
- You know what's amazing?
Oh, here we go.
Is my controller working?
It is working.
- You got it.
I'm not gonna go easy on you.
You better get your controller right.
- Okay, it works, it works, it works.
- Oh snap.
- See, I don't know how to do the fire.
The fire just happens.
Oh, well he blocked my fire.
That's literally the only move I have.
- There is so much lag and I'm not making
up an excuse here.
(Xolo laughing)
You guys feel it too, right?
That's a lot of lag.
- I think it's a little bit of latency
in controller response.
Oh, oh, oh.
- Hey, whoa, watch out.
- No, no, no, no, no.
No, no.
- [Jacob] Get back, get back, get back.
- Oh, time ran out.
- Oh, time is over.
- Oh, come on.
(game bleeping)
- That's still a win.
- Game.
- I don't think I can accept that win.
That was not a win in my heart.
- [Jacob] I'll say that was still close.
- For some reason, I cannot do moves.
- You can't move?
- Yeah, I can't do a Hadouken because...
There we go.
- I blocked that.
I didn't even realize I could block.
Okay, that's good.
That's a good start.
Get back, get back, get back.
I don't want that Hadouken.
No!
- Oh, shh.
- [Jacob] He's got the Hadouken now, dude.
- I'm sorry.
- You gotta get in there.
- He's got the Hadouken.
- [Jacob] You better get in there, bro.
(everyone yelling)
You're beating the Hadouken.
- Here's where the real
pain begins, Danny Boy.
That's a quote from
three, if you'd seen it.
I don't read my scripts so I don't know
who I'm bragging to.
- All right, this is for all the marbles.
Let's go, Gianni.
- Oh my god.
- Come on.
- Okay, this actually,
there's a lot at stake here.
- Oh, you blocked it, all right.
- Come on, Loofy.
- Did you call me goofy?
- No, Loofy.
- No, I said Loofy.
- He really is Loofy.
I don't think Loofy would be so granular.
- Oh, come on.
Just button mashing...
- I'm spamming.
- He's dizzy!
- Come on, come on, come on.
- Gianni!
- I'm sorry, Gianni!
- I need to move.
I gotta move, I gotta move, I gotta move.
Oh, come on, Gianni.
- No, nine, six, five,
four, three, two, no.
- No, no, no.
- Oh my god.
- Oh, Gianni, no.
- You can not do a fireball in this thing.
- And he beat you with the controller.
- All right, I'll hold it down.
I'll avenge, I'll avenge.
- Oh, is it Jacob's turn?
- I'm tapping in my binary bro.
- Hawk, Hawk, Hawk.
- Okay, what controller were you doing?
- I was controller two.
- Two?
- Yeah, I was two.
- All right, come on.
- I'm just gonna stay
as Ryu, 'cause he's wearing the headband
and I've got the Daniel lotus headband
and Miyagi gear on, so let's do it.
- Okay, we're using
the yellow goblin neck.
All right, you can leave
the call now, Gianni.
You've been wiped out.
- (laughing) Honestly,
after that last performance,
I think I'm done here.
I think I have to quit the show
and I need to take up
gardening or something else.
- Bro, the Hadouken was brutal.
- Dude, I don't know how to combat that.
- Because for some reason,
it's not registering the
input on this controller,
my thumb's gone numb.
So my ability to do Hadoukens
has diminished for spamming.
- You hear that Jacob-
- You beat Gianni
and he was like, all right.
You loosened the jar, Gianni.
- Yeah, I loosened it.
I got you.
Now this should be a cake walk.
- Man, he's winning.
- He's winning.
- Yes.
- Brutal.
Okay, here we go.
- Oh my god.
- Go Shrek, go Shrek, okay.
- Jacob! Done me dirty.
- I don't know how to
do the lightning thing.
That thing is oh my god.
- Yeah, scoop him.
- Aw, shoot, bro.
- No, no, not yet.
- Not yet, not yet.
- You have to survive.
- Jacob.
- You just have to survive it.
- I can't do a combo on this controller.
Oh shit.
(everyone yelling)
- Jacob, I loosened the jar for you.
- I couldn't figure out how to do a sweep.
- Oh, we can't let Rahul beat us up, man.
- Yeah!
- Oh my god.
- Bro, the sweep might beat him.
- No.
- Do you see Jacob?
- Oh, headbutt.
- No, I can't see him.
- No, Jacob, doing me dirty again
with this zombie move!
- This is graphic.
There's no blood particles.
- Okay, Karen.
- I'm not okay with this.
Oh, Jacob.
- Jacob, don't do me dirty.
- Survive.
Oh, okay, okay.
It's going into the third round at least.
Okay, okay, okay.
- All right, here we go, baby.
This is the deciding round.
- We got this, bro, we got this.
- Sweep the leg, Jacob.
- He's still dead.
Why is he still dead?
- Do it.
- Thank god.
- This is more eventful
than the new one I've had.
- The head butt.
- Don't grab me, don't grab me.
- That older guy has my
posture from season one.
- No.
No, thank you.
That was a little karate move there.
- What is that supposed to be?
- Oh, there you go, Jacob.
Get him.
- Oh, Jacob, no.
- Yeah, baby!
- That's my boy (clapping).
That's my binary brother.
- I got you, Gianni.
- I have nothing to say, dude.
That was, yeah, you got me.
- I've avenged my death.
- All right, I'm tapping in.
- Be careful.
- You got it, Xolo.
- All right, so Xolo versus Jacob?
- Come on.
- All right, let's do it, Jacob.
- Yeah, you two.
It's winner stays on.
- Oh, okay.
- It's king of the hill, baby.
- I'm under a lot of pressure.
- How long were you guys
shooting that fight scene
in the high school?
That one was epic.
- That was only three days.
- You did that in three days?
- Was it three days?
- Three days because we
rehearsed two weekends.
- We rehearsed weekends.
It was two weekends, but we were only able
to film it in three days,
which is not a lot of time,
if you guys are back home.
Three days, even though
it seems like a lot,
it is practically nothing.
- Yeah, the idea-
- The last day-
- Yeah, the last day was just,
I think you and Gianni had the last scene
of the whole season, right?
- Xolo, how long did you get
to just lie in a bed for?
- Honestly, that-
- Is that like a month
worth of filming?
- Well, it's funny because I think
even though it seemed it
was a bunch of episodes,
we were able to film all
of them in like two days,
so it was nice, I got to-
- You guys move quick.
- Since they already know we're gonna be
in the hospital-
- Oh, you can just drop
it and get it in three.
- Boom, boom, boom, boom.
- Gotcha, gotcha.
All right, the scene
with you at the concert
was one of my favorites.
- Which one?
- When you and Johnny William,
you guys go to the concert,
when you're in the wheelchair.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Was one of my favorite scenes
of that season.
- With Dee Snider?
Yeah, that guy's a legend.
All righty, hey,
get off my head!
- Oh my god.
Oh my god.
- That's so nice.
- Let's go, baby.
Yeah, you got a cheap shot at me
in the beginning, bro.
- I think Jacob is the best at this.
He has a weight advantage, bro.
- You chose your character.
- That's nice.
That's nice from Xolo there.
Xolo, if you mash your kick button.
Mash your kick button, Xolo.
She does this kick.
- No, bro, don't do this to me.
I'm confused.
- Get on the ground, boy.
- Yeah, if you, as Chun Li, Xolo,
if you mash your light kick,
you have a version of his electricity
that will rapidly does a-
- Which button is that?
- Wherever your kick
is, if you just mash it.
Yeah, that one, that one.
Keep doing it.
(Xolo yelling)
- What, what the heck?
- Dude, just keep spamming that.
- Finish him.
- Oh my god.
- That was my Creese impression.
- That was a really good one.
- I can't, I can't, I can't.
I can't unleash him.
No!
- Who's gonna?
- No fricking way.
- Jacob.
- No!
- Aite, put some respect on my name.
- We're not gonna get
Jacob off this controller.
- All right, guys, all right.
All right, I want a rematch.
I can do this.
What are you, controller two?
- I was controller one.
- It's like if I was
a superhero and my weakness
was a little tiny slug
that was horrible against
everyone else except me.
That's like Gianni.
He's my little weakness.
- I'm your little weakness?
Why do you have to put
me down like that, man?
- I mean, "little weakness"
that's taller than everyone here, man.
- I'm six feet tall.
The only one taller than me is Silver.
Oh, okay, here we go.
- Okay, so we got Dhalsim versus Blanka.
Gianni moves quick.
- I like just doing the button mashing.
- Dude, that electricity thing is rough.
- Come on, let me see it, let me see it.
Come on, come on, let me see it.
- Jacob, if you move
backwards for three seconds,
then press forward with punch,
you'll do a spin attack.
- No, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
- Dude, the eating of the head is -
- No, oh!
- Jacob plays like such a troll.
He's either electrocuting you
or he's munching on your face.
If you break away he headbutts you.
There's no honor in your fighting, Jacob.
It's street fighting
and I appreciate that.
- That's 'cause it's Hawk, baby.
- That is all Hawk.
You absolutely fight like Hawk.
- How did it push you?
- Yeah, you can't close to him.
- Do you guys have a
personal favorite scene
from the last three seasons?
Obviously we can't talk
about four too much
but do you have a
favorite scene from each?
- Yeah, I really like when Demetri
got his arm broken.
That was really funny.
- Thanks, I appreciate that.
That was funny.
- That was brutal.
I liked it when Miguel
folded over a school railing
into a 90 degree angle.
- I got folded like a taco.
- I'd say my favorite scene is my brush.
That's my favorite scene for sure.
- I love any scene that they play
that Hawk screech whenever
you show your back,
that they add.
- Oh, dude, that's how you
know when shit's getting real.
- Jacob, are you still undefeated now?
- I won, bro, what do you mean?
Why do you say that?
- He's undefeated.
He just ate my face.
- I think my Hadouken thumb is healed.
I probably could go.
Should we try one more?
- All right, I think you
should hop on for another one.
- Okay, all right, one more.
We'll do this.
This will be the decider.
Also, my sister and my
mom's gonna kill me if...
This is so cheeky of me 'cause this
isn't even in the script.
Would you say hello to my
mum and my sister, Nadia?
They are the biggest "Cobra Kai" fans.
- What's up mom?
- What's up sister Nadia
- Sister, you're the best.
- I love you guys.
Thank you so much for doing that.
Okay, so let's do this one more time.
- All right, here we go, baby.
All right, see if I can
keep the dubs alive.
- Daniel Lewis is gonna fight.
Daniel Lewis is gonna fight!
- I like that.
- Let's just switch this up.
Let's get one different song,
let's go to Japan.
Oh no, we're going to go to Guile's Stage.
That's got the best music.
If I can do this, my thumb has no feeling.
Oh, guess we'll go to Thailand then.
All right, I'm just pressing start.
- There we go.
- Okay, here we go.
- That's pretty cool.
- I hate how your character just did that.
- You kicked him so hard.
- He's sweet.
He's like Pikachu's ugly cousin.
- There we go.
- There's the move.
- He looks like Rumpelstiltskin
had a baby with Shrek.
- Oh my god.
- There we go, that beats, that beats.
- Oh, Jacob.
- Will he be dethroned?
- I want a hawk screech if I beat you.
- I don't even know if I can,
I'm not even the one that does it.
I don't even know where
do they get that from.
- Isn't it like a-
- Just go full out, even if it's bad.
You have to scream at
the top of your lungs.
Just do it!
- What, your kick is longer than my kick?
- I've got thumbs for it, come on.
- Oh no, Jacob, Jacob.
- Come on, dude, yore literally-
- Oh my god.
- Oh, you gotta
do the screech, full volume.
- You got a full volume screech.
- Your best hawk impression.
- Like as loud as you
can, hurt your throat.
You have nothing you're doing tomorrow.
You have nowhere to be.
You don't need your voice.
(Jacob screeching)
- That was amazing.
- And most people just left the live.
- (laughing) Most people
had to cut it out.
- You owe people new
computers all around the grid.
- We should get that on instant replay
over and over again.
- Can we get that in reverse.
- Guys, this was
the best dream I've ever had, honestly.
- But you gotta wake up from this dream.
You gotta wake up, bro.
- This is just a dream, man.
You gotta wake up, man.
- All right, guys.
- Wake up!
- You gotta wake up.
(voices echoing)
(dream sequence music)